good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight the true measure of
character a wise man once said is not
whether you make a mistake all of us do
but whether you learn from that mistake
with those words in mind we'd like to
begin tonight with an admission it's
contrition night on fox news it is time
to reassess
our view of kamala harris now if you
watch the show you know that for more
than a year now we've had a pretty
conventional understanding of this
country's first black slash indian slash
part canadian vice president who also
happens to identify as a woman
now we've assumed that kamala harris was
historically unpopular because she's
historically incompetent and fake we
assume she earned her low approval
numbers and we're not alone in that lots
of other people have come to the very
same conclusion there's currently a
debate among software engineers about
whether harris is even of biological
origin or instead the product of a
classified government ai project gone
wrong
we don't know the answer but we
certainly understand the question she's
that synthetic
so again until the other day we assume
that people don't like kamala harris
because she's highly unlikable
keep in mind that even her own husband
kisses her with a mask on to us that
seemed like a pretty clear sign
but we're here tonight to tell you that
assumptions can change even assumptions
rooted in overwhelming evidence and
observable reality
sometimes and this happens your entire
world view can flip upside down
instantly invert in a flash of light
as saul of tarsus
our road to damascus experience came
when we saw this clip of joy reid from
msnbc doing a drive time radio show
watching it we realized the problem
isn't kamala harris
the problem is us
so take a look at this open your mind a
little bit and see if you don't come to
the same life-changing conclusion that
we did here's joy reid
i think for kamala harris she's had like
the triple problem of being a woman and
so people not being willing to respect
her the way they would respect the male
vice president of being black which we
already know that what that carries with
it is the anti-blackness comes you know
with the package and then also being
vice president at a time that is really
really difficult joey and i talk about
this all the time madam vice president
and you know this charlemagne see black
black okay she went to howard she a.k.a
when she talks to you yeah it is i mean
she's she's so regular she's so regular
and i just it's unfortunate that more
people don't see that and there's also
just the dumbing down of the american
electorate you know people don't
understand civics they don't understand
politics they don't understand how
things
work did you hear that have you
internalized it have you brought it deep
inside let it marinate a little bit
people who don't like kamala harris are
sexist obviously because like admiral
rachel levine she identifies as a woman
too they're also racist because kamala
harris is the daughter of a jamaican
college professor duh
and by the way they're also stupid by
definition they know nothing about
civics or american politics it's the
dumbing down of america unlike kamala
harris you don't quote understand how
things work
so the takeaway is kamala harris isn't
unpopular because she's a bad person
she's unpopular because you're a bad
person you're the problem your racism is
hurting kamala harris's political career
damn you bigot
and then we realize how's this for mind
bending joy reid was talking about us
and then we broke down and shed the
bitter tears of self-awareness
and our journey of education began we
wanted to know more so we found an
interview that joy reid recently did
with a black supremacist website called
the root a website that's now a
permanent fixture in our favorites tab
rita's the child of well-educated
african immigrants grew up in a white
neighborhood in denver and went to
harvard
so naturally she's got a gut level
understanding of the historic black
experience in america the way you do
when you're from denver went to harvard
you just feel it it's just part of you
the way it's part of kamala harris after
growing up in montreal
as jeremy put it quote kamal is just a
regular sister in the same way people
would always say that michelle obama is
like your sister if your cousin became
first lady
kamala harris is like if your cousin
became vice president of the united
states i think she doesn't get to show
that personality often enough and so
people haven't had a chance to know her
you following this
so kamala harris is like your sister in
the same way that michelle obama would
be like your sister if your sister was
your cousin and also married to the
president
why hadn't we realized that before
well as joy reid pointed out quote most
of the media is still white and male of
course
those damn white males always hiding the
sister cousin connection that's what
they do
but for us the veil had been lifted
we could see for the first time what our
racism had blinded us to for so long and
the truth heard it was so painful that
for days we had to wear sunglasses even
indoors
but it was worth it because at that
point began a journey of contrition and
self-discovery that honestly was long
overdue
like adam kinziger we finally faced the
truth about ourselves
and were moved to weeping by what we saw
how could we be so darn racist that's
the question we're asking ourselves
tonight in the fading light of this
year's juneteenth observance
so that was the old us we've shed it
like a snakeskin it's time to change
it's time to do better it's time to
think anew tonight
about what we thought we knew
about kamala harris
so we're going to take a look at some of
the sound bites we have mocked on this
show over the last year and a half and
boy doesn't it feel good just to admit
fault
just to say to the world yes
we're not perfect we get it wrong
sometimes
but not anymore
we have fresh eyes and with those eyes
we're going to assess this footage in a
brand new way
so here's tape of harris repeating the
very same line about quote speaking
truth we used to make fun of this
not anymore
one of the most important values that i
think we must fight for is is to speak
truth and we will speak truth about the
injustice we will speak truth about the
inequity we will speak truth about the
unfairness and let's speak truth let's
speak truth
so let's speak some truth and we must
speak truth no matter how uncomfortable
it may be to hear
we need to speak truth we have to speak
truth one must speak truth
and that we speak truth and we must have
the courage
to speak truth someone who has the
courage to speak truth um i applaud her
courage to speak truth and let's speak
the biggest truth
the biggest truth of all
so our assumption really for decades was
that politicians who make a habit of
using the word truth are probably really
by definition lying that's why they say
truth so often i'm not cheating i
promise
but what really struck us the old us
was the fact that common or camelot you
know it doesn't matter how you pronounce
her name it just doesn't matter that's
the other thing we've realized she
doesn't know how neither do we we'll
admit it
but what struck us was that she repeats
the same line again and again and again
and her old reactions was derision not
exactly socrates that was the phrase we
used
but that reaction we now see comes from
a place of privilege evaluate your
priors deconstruct your unconscious bias
and ask yourself
would a [ __ ] be capable of repeating
the same canned phrase dozens of times
with this kind of precision without
changing a single facial expression oh
no
try that at home you can't do it you're
too self-aware
it's impossible for you
but not for kamala harris
she's got what it takes to repeat
herself verbatim for days at a time
behaving as if each time is the first
time
we stand corrected and we stand in awe
here she was in may telling us about the
importance of and we're quoting
working together
we will work together and continue to
work together
to address these issues to tackle these
challenges
and to work together as we continue to
work
operating from the new norms rules and
agreements
that we will convene
to work together on
so again we laughed at that clip we've
done it more than once ah it feels good
to admit it
at the time we assumed kamala harris
just got lost in the middle of a
sentence she couldn't find her way out
together working together
how do i get out of this sentence
together
but now we see what was really happening
here kamala harris fully understands
the importance of working together not
just working but together working
together
and that's not something we should mock
that's brilliant and science has proven
it's brilliant
ten years ago researchers at trinity
college in dublin ireland found and were
quoting
proof that evolution of intelligence and
larger brain sizes can be driven by
do you know what by and we're quoting
cooperation and teamwork in other words
working together
so when kamala harris tells us again and
again and again that we need to work
together she's not simply repeating some
vapid canned sound bite she's been
handed by her handlers no
she's literally literally moving human
evolution forward
she's making the species better on a
cellular level how long till we can fly
if kamala harris keeps it up not long
she does this all the time
she makes us better and as she does she
does her homework
as joy reid told us
it's the dumbing down of america the
dummies here can't see it but kamala
harris can because she's done the work
here she was on monday talking to kids
at the national museum of african
american history
today is a day
to celebrate the principle of freedom
and think about it in terms of the
context of history
knowing that black people in america
were not free for 400 years of slavery
okay so again there are a couple of
different ways to assess that claim the
old us
before we were reborn
and since we're dealing in cliches now
we're just going to compare ourselves to
a phoenix
before we rose from the ashes anew the
old us would have said wait a second
kamala harris
african americans weren't actually
enslaved for 400 years in this country
that's not true but we would have missed
the point
so what happened here is that kamal
harris before her talk googled how long
was her slavery in america and she saw
that it had been 400 years since slavery
began in america which is true but she
forgot to subtract the years since the
emancipation proclamation
it's actually fewer than 400 about a 150
years fewer than 400 which would put us
around 250 but whatever
the point is that's not her fault
it's google's fault for not doing the
subtraction for her
talk about falling short of the promise
of the internet and who runs google hmm
joy read anyone white men
so there's a lot of white supremacy in
palo alto california as google has
already admitted
not convinced yet well then you're just
a bad person and you're also jealous you
know what you're jealous of above all
not just the brilliance not just the
tenacity
you're jealous of kamala or camel it
doesn't matter you're jealous over joy
what did you think when you watched that
hearing
i will tell you
joy
i experienced great
joy
when i watch this brilliant
phenomenal
black woman
jurist
be so smart
and i watched that with incredible joy
because it was just brilliance
being displayed
for the entire country to see
and i cannot wait to see if that will
only be matched by the joy
that i experience
when i see her take the oath
to be the next justice on the united
states supreme court
not just brilliant
but also
phenomenal
so ask yourself and be totally honest
and put the thristaurus away
how many synonyms could you come up with
in a row
extemporaneously just top of your head
not just brilliant but phenomenal could
you do that
no you couldn't
and by the way you don't have her joy
maybe that's why you don't like her we
don't know we can only tell you about
our journey subscribe to the fox news
youtube channel to catch our nightly
opens stories that are changing the
world and changing your life from tucker
carlson tonight